I in the sample I will demonstrate how
to call a cloud run app from apigee I
will use cloud build to deploy a
cloud.application and use RPG pivot
deployed plugin to deploy sample proxy
long run is a managed compute platform
that lets you work continues directly on
top of Google's scalable infrastructure
and cloudwind is a fully managed
continuous integration delivery and
deployment platform that lets you run
fast consistent and reliable automated
bill
the prerequisite for the samples are
have an apigee exposition and configure
external access for API traffic as a
usen you will need access to deploy a
proxy to apigee deploy an application to
Cloud grid and also trigger a cloud
build job in your GSP project
have tools like gcloud unzip curd and GQ
installed
this sample can be demonstrated using
the cloud shell QuickStart tutorial or
following this setup instruction
in this video we will use the cloud
shell Quick Start
click the open in Cloud shell
to open the cloud shell environment
once the environment is loaded
so let's follow the instructions
provided in the tutorial
first we will set up environment
we will authenticate with gcp
then we will go to Cloud run directory
we need to set up environment variables
for that we need to edit environment dot
asset
file
and add some variables
so in this case our project is
we will set other variables
once all the variables are set we will
save this file
and
we will run the source command
to initiate this variables in my shell
before we deploy the cloud and samples
we need to enable
IM API Cloud build API Cloud run API and
container registry API
once these apis are enabled
we need to assign RPG on admin role
Cloud run admin and service account
admin and user role to the cloud build
service account
now we need to trigger Cloud build
but before we trigger the cloud pin
let's look at the application that we
need to deploy in the cloud trend
so application is available in the app
directory
and you can look at the app.js file
which is a simple node.js application
which
prints
a text mock Target service
then let's look at the cloud build.yaml
file
the first step is to build container
image
then it pushes the container image to
container registry
then it deploys that image to Cloud run
s it is deployed
apigee needs
a service account with invoker rule to
access cloudtrap so test step
sets those variable and creates the the
service account
before it runs the maven to deploy
apigee proxy
it leads to change the target URL to to
that of the cloud uh run and point URL
and once all these variables are set
you run
deploy bundle step
to deploy
the apigee proxy
now let's go and Trigger the Cloud Print
this process takes some time
the cloud build is finished
you can see that the service call mock
Target is deployed in Cloud run
and a practical sample Cloud run is
deployed in apigee
you can test the API call to make sure
the deployment was successful
as you can see it returns mock Target
service
don't forget to clean up this
thanks for watching I hope this content
was useful to you if you have not signed
up for apigee yet use this link and if
you have any questions please visit the
apigee community